des illusions ans françois bayrou qui
cependant n'est plus seul au centre
la troisième voie de la vie politique
est désormais une terre de conquête pour
d'autres on voit tout cela avec valérie
astruc benoît jourdan et nicolas voir
hervé morin dominique de villepin
françois bayrou jean-louis borloo quatre
hommes avec officiellement un même
message de votre la famille centriste
prennent l'habitude de dialoguer vous
n'êtes pas des ennemis
il faut regrouper cette femme et
travailler en direction des différents
groupes centristes parce qu'il n'y en
aura qu'un le centre objet de toutes les
convoitises car à deux ans de la
présidentielle l'électorat modéré gros
si on assiste à une polarisation de la
vie polluent la vie politique avec une
gauche qui assume d'être assez à gauche
voire très à gauche et une droite qui
assume d'être clairement de droite
décomplexée avec ce qui s'est passé cet
été notamment sur la sécurité les roms
et du coup ça libère un espace aux
semble cet espace et ses alliés à 20% de
l'électorat
du coup chacun montre ses muscles
françois bayrou a carrément former un
gouvernement virtuel une petite troupe
largement composée d'inconnus
mais le béarnais croit dur comme fer le
centre c'est lui les autres sont vendus
à nicolas sarkozy quiconque prononce le
mot centre il doit avoir une attitude
indépendante
il doit pas être chez od salut dans sa
ligne de mire
hervé morin et jean louis borloo tous
deux disponibles pour incarner le centre
droit en 2012
mais à nice mardi dernier thé françois
fillon que les centristes at no 10
françois fillon qui se charge de
refroidir les ardeurs
certains d'entre vous s'interrogent déjà
sur l'élection présidentielle je leur
demande de prendre le temps de la
réflexion
enfin dominique de villepin et le
nouveau venu de la famille appel vibrant
à former un arc central mais accueil
glacial de ses concurrents
il peint il n'a jamais été centriste
pour mettre bon pied chaque jour le
centre un enfer pavé de bonnes
intentions
je